when people ask me how did we see the
scenes from August 2021 where Afghans
were running under the tarmac they were
jumping on the aircraft uh Wheels trying
to fly out of the country they're
handing babies over the uh barbed wire
topped walls of the Airfield it's Joe
Biden's rank
uh incompetence that caused all that we
knew this was coming he was warned that
it was coming he was warned by members
of his own Administration worn by senior
military officials and he simply did not
listen to them in fact just five weeks
before the fall of Afghanistan he was
saying there was no way we would see a
scene like we saw in Saigon in 1975 we
had to shamefully take off from our
Embassy in helicopters that's exactly
what we saw and it was because of Joe
Biden's weakness
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is a
senator from the great state of Arkansas
as well as author of the new book Only
the Strong reserving the left's plot to
sabotage American power I think you held
it with the title Senator Tom Cotton
welcome to the Reuben report hey Dave
thanks for having me on it's a real
pleasure and I look forward to talking
to you about it I want to be strong
today well I've wanted to talk to you
for quite some time and basically this
book is a layout of an awful lot of the
history of the lunacy that I've been
fighting against on this show so first
off what what caused you to write this
book I mean you're a senator you're
you're fighting the madness in DC all
the time what made you say hey I want to
go back and look at where some of this
came from and and where it's going
well David all started last year in the
aftermath of the Afghanistan Fiasco
um at first I was astonished at Joe
Biden's bumbling then my team and I
spent a couple weeks in August trying to
do everything we could to get our
kansans and other Americans out of
Afghanistan but as we reflected on it in
the days after our departure from
Afghanistan I had so many people ask how
could this happen how could we lose to a
medieval band of savages but it also
went deeper to that to things they had
seen in recent years Bill and writers
rampaging in our streets and tearing
down statues of Our Heroes trying to
defund the police and at least attacking
the police when they couldn't defund
them and somehow illegitimate Calling
America systemically racist and
oppressive which led to a crime wave all
across our country America being a
laughing stock at the hands of our
adversaries around the world and at the
bottom of all those questions I thought
was how did it get to this point why
doesn't America win anymore and I wanted
to lay out for my readers exactly how
the left in America has for over 100
years plotted the sabotage American
power now I'm not claiming that liberals
and Democrats are necessarily
Un-American or they hate our country
although plenty are and plenty do but at
best they're ambivalent about America
their anguished about our past and
uncertain about our future and that's
why they've taken the steps over the
last hundred years they have taken to
weaken our military to entangle us in a
network of globalist international
institutions to bring American sources
of energy offline while we make
ourselves more dependent on China all
these steps are part of their effort to
make America just another country a more
normal place that doesn't view itself as
exceptional or special or that has any
special role attributed to it by God and
by our Founders and I wanted to lay out
that case in Only the Strong as well as
a road map of the future
so before we dive too much into the
specifics and everything that you just
said there is exactly what the book is
about since you mentioned Afghanistan
and that was sort of the Genesis of why
you decided to do this can you talk a
little bit of what it was like to be a
senator the few days before when it's
when the withdrawal is happening and
then after like how much information did
you have did you guys try to push back
on on the withdrawal at least how it was
done perhaps and just were you just
ignored or was were there any other
plans laid out that wouldn't have been
as messy as what we all saw
um yes a lot of us did try to explain
that what we saw in August was likely to
happen we didn't necessarily predict the
exact timing or fashion but the reason
why uh Donald Trump never withdrew from
Afghanistan in four years despite the
fact that he obviously wanted to was
because he was worried that it would
lead to a collapse of the Afghan
government and a return of the Taliban
to power which would imperil America's
interest and threaten Americans here and
abroad but Joe Biden came into office
and he said to hell with all that
remember in 2009 as I lay out in Only
the Strong he had insisted then on
cutting and running immediately and as
Barack Obama's own Secretary of Defense
Bob Gates said he subjected President
Obama to something like Chinese water
torture when everyone else was trying to
get Barack Obama off the dime to make a
decision on Afghanistan to commit the
troops necessary to achieve the strategy
he himself had proclaimed in the 2008
campaign Joe Biden kept nattering in his
ear ceding mistrust with our military
saying this Mission could never be
accomplished and he carried a chip on
his shoulder for 12 years that Barack
Obama didn't listen to him and I think
he got into office in 2021 and his toxic
combination of incompetence and
insecurity led him to want to think want
to prove that he had been right all
along that Barack Obama and the generals
and all of those Republicans and
Democrats who had criticized him for 12
years were wrong so in April 2021 when
he said we're going to rip the Band-Aid
off does it matter if Taliban has
fulfilled the conditions that President
Trump uh set for them in the withdrawal
agreement from 2020 we're just going to
get out and most perversely of all said
we're going to get out by 9 11 as if
that were somehow a great way to honor
the sacrifices and the losses that we
suffered on that day and in everyday
since then and as time passed from April
to August it was clear to me partly
based on public reports partly based on
the intelligence we're receiving that
president President Biden had not taken
the steps necessary to get all Americans
out to get their family members out to
get out green card holders to get out
the loyal Afghans who had served
alongside us and they were trending
towards a disaster and when people ask
me how did we see the scenes from August
2021 where Afghans were running under
the tarmac they were jumping on the
aircraft uh Wheels trying to fly out of
the country they're handing babies over
the uh barbed wire topped walls of the
Airfield it's Joe Biden's rank
incompetence that caused all that we
knew this was coming he was warned that
it was coming he was warned by members
of his own Administration worn by senior
military officials and he simply did not
listen to them in fact just five weeks
before the fall of Afghanistan he was
saying there's no way we would see a
scene like we saw in Saigon in 1975
which had to shamefully take off from
our Embassy in helicopters that's
exactly what we saw and it was because
of Joe Biden's weakness
what do you think a clean effective
withdrawal would have looked like so for
those of us that you know it was the
longest war in American history in
essence over over 20 years it was
unclear to a lot of people why we were
there at this point certainly my more
libertarian side thought we shouldn't
have even be been there in the first
place but at some point if you're going
to wrap these things up it seems like it
always is going to be somewhat messy
what do you think a a decent withdrawal
actually would have looked like well
Dave first I want to go back to the
beginning of the Afghan war which was
almost universally supported in the
Congress by the American people since
that's the land from which Osama Bin
Laden and Al Qaeda had attacked us
having been given Safe Harbor without
Taliban there's no question that we took
a lot of twists and turns in Afghanistan
as we did in Iraq that we shouldn't have
taken our main interest in Afghanistan
was to ensure that it couldn't be used
as a training ground and launching pad
for further attacks our interest there
was not try to try to remake Afghan
culture it wasn't try to improve
literacy or bring Economic Development
all those are good things with Afghan
people certainly but it's not in
America's core interest of those things
happen so there are many points along
the way when we should have taken stock
and said we're no longer serving our
Vital national interests here one was in
2009 and then again in 2011 Barack Obama
announced a new strategy but telegraphy
it wasn't committed to it I'd been there
right before that announcement I'd heard
a lot from Afghans uh about their
traditional proverb you have the watches
but we have the time unfortunately that
proved to be right what a final
departure from Afghanistan could have
looked like it probably should have
looked like under the circumstances that
President Trump and later President
Biden inherited was ensuring that there
was enough Technical and logistical
support to the Afghan Army to make sure
it didn't collapse as I write not only
the strong President Biden didn't just
withdraw our troops he withdrew the
Western mechanics and contractors that
kept the Afghan Air Force flying these
kinds of troops or even these kind of
civilian contractors they're not
Frontline trigger pullers they're not
door kickers they're not going on waves
against the Taliban but their president
presence did give the Afghan Army a lot
of moral support a lot of material
support that would have allowed them
perhaps to maintain conditions across
the country that would have forced the
Taliban to negotiate some kind of
political outcome as opposed to enable
the Taliban to seize the entire country
in a span of just a few weeks last
summer do you know if Biden had anyone
in his I mean look he's probably not
going to listen to Tom Cotton but do you
know if he had anyone in his ear in the
administration that was going Hey Joe
this thing is not going to go as planned
we're going to get horrific images
they're going to take all our weapons
etc etc he did almost everyone frankly
uh certainly his uniform military
leaders but also a lot of his fellow
Democrats the people he appointed to
high positions look they wanted to get
out of Afghanistan just like Donald
Trump just like Barack Obama for him but
they also knew the dangerous
consequences that would follow if we did
what Joe Biden did just simply pull up
Stakes without any plan to keep country
and the government's stable there and
it's not just Afghanistan you saw within
weeks of the withdrawal from Afghanistan
Vladimir Putin beginning to Marshal
troops on the border of Ukraine there's
a dangerous Afghan effect now just like
there was a dangerous Vietnam syndrome
after Vietnam that will reverberate and
harm our country's interest at least as
long as Joe Biden is president if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell